okay I'm curious who's the most famous
person you have their contact in your
phone oh it's a sick question okay I
would have to scroll through it I'd like
I have a weird habit of breaking my
phone so I get a new phone like every
year just like dropping in water or
whenever we're filming it falls out of
something uh but just a kid from North
Carolina you know what I mean the rock
all of a sudden you get a contact in
your phone you go wow I'm doing it
Michelle Obama no no Obama's Malia Obama
I keep throwing some names I'd have to
scroll through I don't even I don't know
Sasha Obama Drake who's the most famous
person we met I'm drawn blank like or I
don't have their number yeah well if we
met him we probably connected with yeah
right
um yeah is it who
just say it you said you're hurting Leo
Leo Leonardo DiCaprio oh yes
baby oh my God why as soon as we bring
up again in one year he's gonna stop
hanging out with you
no I have a dick for good yeah wait so
how did you meet Leo what happened
um all his girlfriends love your videos
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you go to Leo's house and the girls are
all like popping out their retainers
like oh my God
that's funny how did that happen I met
him at an event there's just like I
don't does I don't know how much I can
say but there's just like this super
exclusive event with just all these
really rich and famous people yeah and I
just did not belong there at the time
yeah yeah and yeah he was just one of
them and how did you get invited to that
event I loved island in the Bahamas well
I think it was
like they're like I remember pulling I
just can't say too much but I just
remember pulling up and there's like
dozens of guys with just like assault
rifles and stuff and I was like oh it's
like it's like that high level yeah of
an event and um yeah and he just was
like I I so I ended up talking up there
so it's like I don't even know how to
put into words like everyone there was
either like Ultra famous or just like a
billionaire they're like very it was
crazy having all those people in that
room
um and then at dinner you just they just
pair you up with random people so you
meet new people and he was the one at
the table and we just and did you give a
speech yeah it was because a lot of them
run companies and things like that so
it's more just like hey invest in
YouTube you're like TV [ __ ] sucks
that's basically what my speech was yeah
yeah and so it's great and do they know
what you're doing like when you meet
these [ __ ] and you're like yeah
200 million people watch this video yeah
most of them know uh because of their
kids to be honest so they're like you
know my kid into the most powerful
influencers in Hollywood by the way I I
believe that's a good thing if we call
them we need something and they say no I
just go just ask your kids yeah and then
five minutes later they're like holy
[ __ ] yeah it's like and and but then if
they're like oh I don't have kids it's
like [ __ ] when I get a show that I got
green lit when I was at MTV the woman
who green lit the shows her kid was a
fan yeah it's
do whatever you need yeah yeah
um because so which I lived for the day
where it's no longer oh my kids love you
I love you yeah which is like every time
they say that I'm like [ __ ] another one
um but wait what was even the question
oh yeah most of them knew me because
they're kids yeah I'm just wondering if
these people like these are people that
they would cry if their TV show got two
million views they would they would be
the greatest day of their life and
you're putting out weekly hundred
million 200 million that's bigger than
the Super Bowl I'm pretty sure yeah so
it's like are they looking at you with
are they looking at the way that they
should or are they purposely trying to
ignore what you're doing because here's
where I think it is right now I think
like we're still you know I think in
like five years there's gonna be a lot
of YouTubers that leverage this
influence and just spin off wildly
successful companies and just kind of
[ __ ] up the status quo I think we're
still at the antithesis of it
um because like
if no one's going to buy these videos or
pay what they should we'll just start
our own Brands and it's already showing
like what you're doing burger and
peaceables and stuff like that so I
think like there's just there are people
who by big YouTubers and now the new
wave are big YouTubers that understand
how to you know use it to leverage it to
sell products so I think it didn't
matter at this point anything that's
commoditized or like like a water bottle
or things like that eventually
influencers are just going to sell it I
love that is your pitch to a company
you're you're you're offering them
salvation yeah you're not going don't
buy an ad you're going I will make you
obsolete I mean that's kind of what
that's a Rockefeller that is yo like
McDonald's you better buy an ad with me
yeah or you won't exist yeah join
standard oil or you or it's over it's
like it's just I don't know anything
that's commoditized and not that hard it
just the influencer can do it but just
make it cooler yeah like think of smart
water and this other stuff that popped
up like you know death did a great job
yeah but you have hundreds of these
people that are just getting bigger and
bigger every single month on social
media and eventually it's just gonna be
more of a predominant thing I am telling
you dude historic human being and that's
why I love that you seem to still have
this Goodwill running through you like I
want to donate Etc because most of the
guys like you are [ __ ] Carnegie or at
least people who build these uh Empires
and don't do [ __ ] and that's why I look
at you and I'm like yo this guy should
be president well that's let's go that's
no and I mean this is a huge compliment
to you and Rogan it's like it's rare
that people that like have that much
power success and influence are
benevolent thank you I mean the thing is
you can make tons of money not doing
good making content or you can just make
tons of money and help people yep and so
it's like this one's just a little bit
more fun to be honest huge thank you to
incogni for sponsoring this clip get
your personal private information off
the internet wipe it clean with
incognate they got your back and if you
use the code Schultz Schulz at the link
below you can get 20 off in cogni okay
protect your privacy today right now all
right use the code Schultz take your
personal data off the market